good evening John a lot of news from  here tonight and we want to start with  what you were just showing the president  over at Walter Reed having a chance to  meet with some of these wounded service  members the president also allowing  cameras into the hospital for this shot  that you're seeing right here the  president along with members of the  armed services and his Secret Service  detail wearing a mask the president  wearing a blue mask with the  presidential seal on the side of it this  is the first time that the pool are  really the main press pools had a chance  to see the president walk around with  this the president had been asked about  whether or not he was going to wear a  mask and now the president doing just  that there's certainly a shot that the  president wanted to see captured on  camera and will be interesting to watch  the fallout from all of this